[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja
Hayali schönen guten Abend die
Terrorgruppe Hamas hat der israelischen
Regierung einen dreiufenplan vorgelegt
er liest sich allerdings eher wie ein
Diktat und stellt unter anderem
Bedingungen für die Freilassung der
verbliebenen Geiseln von den 136 die ja
noch in der Gewalt der Hamas sind sollen
inzwischen 31 tot sein der israelische
premmier Netanyahu steht deshalb
innenpolitisch weiter unter Druck der
wird durch die USA auch noch etwas
erhöht l
walpot israelische Soldaten inspizieren
einen hamastunnel in hanunes 12 Geiseln
sollen hier zeitweise eingesperrt
gewesen sein wo sie jetzt sind das
wissen die Soldaten nicht mindestens 31
der mehr als 100 Männer Frauen und
Kinder sind nach armeeerkenntnissen
schon tot seit Monaten machen Angehörige
Druck auf die Regierung Netanyahu mehr
für die Freilassung der Geiseln zu tun
bislang
vergeblich die Terrorgruppe Hamas
antwortete heute auf einen
internationalen Vermittler Vorschlag ihr
Angebot Freilassung der verbliebenen
Geiseln innerhalb von 135 Tagen aber
gegen umfangreiche Bedingungen unter
anderem Einstellung der
Kämpfe wir brauchen außerdem mehr
Hilfslieferungen für die leidende
Bevölkerung Notunterkünfte und den
kompletten Wiederaufbau der zerstörten
Infrastruktur daneben fordert Hamas auch
die Freilassung von 1500
palästinensischen Häftlingen aus
israelischen Gefängnissen den Vorschlag
müsse man eingehend prüfen so
usßenminister blinken unterwegs in der
Region um eine Feuerpause und die
Freilassung der Geiseln zu erreichen für
seine israelischen Partner aber steht
fest den Maximalforderungen der Hamas
kann man nicht
zustimmen wir sind auf dem Weg zum
totalen Sieg und dieser Sieg ist in
greifbarer Nähe es ist nicht eine Frage
von Jahren sondern eine von ein paar
Monaten nur weiterer militärischer Druck
wird die Geiseln befreien den abstrusen
Forderungen der Hamas nachzugeben das
wird nicht helfen im Gegenteil es wird
Grundlage für neue Massaker
bieten nicht viel Spielraum für Blinken
der am Nachmittag Palästinenser
Präsident Abbas in ramala traf wo der
Amerikaner wenig willkommen
ist der Hamas Vorschlag enthält zwar
unannehmbares aber er lässt trotzdem
Raum für eine
Übereinkunft unterdessen kündigte Israel
eine Ausweitung seines Militäreinsatzes
auf Rafa an der Grenze zu Ägypten an
dort leben mehr als eine Million
Flüchtlinge fragen wir nach bei
lckwalport in Tel Aviv lck die
Terrorgruppe will also einen umfassenden
Waffenstillstand das lehnt Israel ab
haben wir gerade in deinem Beitrag
gehört wäre denn eine vorübergehende
Feuerpause
denkbar aus Sicht der Hamas vermutlich
nicht denn das Angebot der Hamas lautet
eben dass man die 135 Tage die man für
die Freilassung der mehr als 100 ge
nutzt
auch dazu nutzt eine endgültige
Friedensvereinbarung wenn man so will
also ein Ende der Kämpfe zu vereinbaren
das sieht israels Regierung ganz anders
wir haben das im Beitrag eben auch
gehört netanahu sagt klar wir stehen
kurz davor die Hamas militärisch zu
besiegen wir dürfen jetzt nicht aufhören
das wäre ein Fehler und das Schicksal
der Geiseln ist da fast nachrangig das
wird so nicht gesagt aber das
militärische Vorgehen gegen die Hamas
hat auf jeden Fall höhere Priorität hier
in Israel und netanahu sagt ja auch
nichts und niemand könne Israel Bremsen
auch die USA
nicht der Druck wächst stetig das hat
auch mit der innenpolitischen Lage in
den USA zu tun es ist ein Wahljahr im
November wird gewählt und US-Präsident
beiden steht unter Druck es die
Demokraten den Demokraten drohen
Stimmverluste wegen ihrer Unterstützung
für Israel aber das hält Netanyahu nicht
ab denn auch der steht innenpitisch
unter Druck und zwar von seinen
Koalitionspartnern den rechtsextrem
Parteien insofern ist da wenig Spielraum
auch für Amerika den Druck noch weiter
zu erhöhen auf Netanyahu der sich da
äußerst robust im Moment zeigt Lück
walport vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzungen live aus Tel Aviv also
die USA sind jedenfalls um Lösungen und
vor allen Dingen um Vermittlung bemüht
usaußenminister blinken war bevor er in
Israel mit Netanyahu sprach zuvor in
Saudi-Arabien in Katar und auch in
Ägypten Claudia Bates ist für uns in
Washington Claudia es war ja jetzt schon
sein fünfter Besuch seit dem 7 oktober
also seit dem Massaker der Terrorgruppe
Hamas haben denn diese ganzen Reisen und
Bemühungen die innenpolitischen Gründe
die wir gerade schon von lck walport
auch gehört haben oder steckt noch ein
bisschen mehr
dahinter also zunächst mal haben die hat
die US-Regierung ein sehr ernsthaftes
Anliegen dass Israel in Frieden leben
kann dass die Geiseln freigelassen
werden dass humanitäre Hilfe nach Gas
gelangt und dass der Konflikt sich nicht
ausweitet auf die größere Region das hat
erstmal nichts mit innenpolitischen
Überlegungen zu tun gleichzeitig gibt es
je weiter die Zeit voranschreitet immer
mehr Gründe schneller zu einer Lösung zu
kommen denn wir haben es gehört wir sind
hier im Wahlkampf und die US-Regierung
wird da zerrieben zwischen der großen
Unterstützung Israels insgesamt aber
auch der Kritik auf der linken Seite der
eigenen demokratischen Partei und auch
die arabischamerikanischen Wähler die
beiden bei der letzten Wahl unterstützt
haben sind enttäuscht von der
proisraelischen Politik der beiden
Regierung jetzt die Republikaner
zeichnen beiden als schwach das schadet
ihm hier und insofern gibt es ja auch
ein innenpolitischen Druck zu einer
Perspektive für eine Lösung zu kommen
viele Gespräche wurden geführt werden
sicherlich noch geführt spricht denn
oder denkt gerade eigentlich
irgendjemand über ein
nachkriegszenario
nach ja nach der Vorstellung der
US-Regierung soll es einen
Palästinenserstaat geben unter einer
palästinensischen Regierung ohne die
Hamas ein Palästinenserstaat von dem
keine Gefahr mehr für Israel ausgehen
dürfte die angestrebte Normalisierung
des Verhältnisses zwischen Israel und
Saudi-Arabien soll fortgeführt werden
und dem Iran klar entgegengetreten
werden es ist hier klar dass es nach dem
Massaker der Hamas am 7 Oktober nicht
mehr so weitergehen kann wie bisher und
insofern sind diese Pläne den USA sehr
wichtig klar ist aber auch dass premier
netanahu da ein sehr schwieriger Partner
ist mit dem das so kaum machbar ist und
auch andere Hindernisse gibt es
natürlich noch zu überwinden insofern ja
ein nachkriegsszenario ist durchaus
entworfen die Frage ist ob das im Moment
mehr sein kann als ein Luftschloss mm
weil du gerade Hindernisse ansprichst
der Senat die Meldung kam vor kurzem
rein hat gerade eben dieses
Milliardenpaket in Höhe von ein ,98
Milliarden Euro abgelehnt darin
enthalten sind ja auch die Hilfen für
Israel und auch die Hilfen für die
Ukraine was bedeutet das jetzt für beide
Länder also weitere Hilfen für Israel
wird es schon geben die Frage ist wann
da der politische Weg dahin sehr geprägt
ist von völligem Chaos hier im Kongress
der Ausgangspunkt war ja ein großes
Paket bei dem es im wesentlichen um die
umstrittene Einwanderungspolitik hier
geht und Teil dieses Pakets waren eben
die Hilfen für die Ukraine und Israel
aber dieses Paket ist an den
Republikanern gescheitert und dann in
einer Hauruckaktion hat das
Repräsentantenhaus die
israelhilfen abgetrennt von dem großen
Paket und allein darüber abgestimmt und
der neue Sprecher des Hauses Johnson ist
mit dieser Idee spektakulär gescheitert
es gab keine Mehrheit dafür also es ist
ein einziges Chaos und sowohl die Hilfe
für Israel als auch die Ukraine sind ein
Kollateralschaden dieses Chaos hier
gleichzeitig gibt es hier bei beiden
Parteien eigentlich eine Mehrheit für
Hilfen für Israel und Sie werden sicher
kommen sobald hier wieder halbwegs
seriös Politik gemacht wird im Kongress
für die Ukraine Hilfen ist es
komplizierter weil mehr Republikaner das
torpedieren und es ist noch nicht klar
wie man da zu einer Lösung kommt und ich
muss mich natürlich korrigieren es sind
109,8 Milliarden Euro um die es geht
Claudia bat vielen Dank nach Washington
für diese
Einschätzung und damit zurück nach
Deutschland Kabinett billigt
Entschärfung des
kinderpornografiegesetzes wer das heute
nur als Schlagzeile gelesen hat dürfte
erst einmal den Kopf geschüttelt haben
warum soll das entschärft werden ganz
einfach wer missbrauchsabbildungen von
Kindern besitzt und sie weiterleitet dem
droh harte Strafen und zwar auch
denjenigen die sie ungewollt erhalten
bzw z.B in einem elternchat als Warnung
teilen das gilt seit
2021 und hat zu zahlreichen Problemen
geführt über die Reform einer Reform
Britta
Spickermann es ist der Fall einer
besorgten Mutter die ins Visier der
Ermittler geriet ihre zehjährige Tochter
hatte in einem Chat eine Fotomontage
entdeckt von Kindergesichtern mit
nackten unterkörpern die Mutter leitete
das Bild weiter weil sie warnen wollte
ich habe eine E-Mail an die Eltern des
Jungen geschrieben der das Bild in den
klassenchat gestellt hat und habe beide
Klassenlehrer in Kopie gesetzt damit
hatte sich die Mutter strafbar gemacht
ihr drohte mindestens ein Jahr
Freiheitsstrafe von tausenden sogar
ztausenden Fällen dieser Art spricht
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann er will
jetzt den Erwerb den Besitz und die
Verbreitung von sogenanntem
kinderpornographischenem Material von
einem Verbrechen auf ein Vergehen wieder
runterstufen ich will noch einmal ganz
klar sagen damit ist in keiner Weise
irgendeine Relativierung dieses
schlimmen Delikts in irgendeiner Form
verbunden unverändert bleibt die
maximale Strafhöhe von bis zu 10 Jahren
Freiheitsstrafe erst 2021 war das
Strafrecht durch seine SPD Vorgängerin
verschärft worden und hatte zu einer
Überlastung der Behörden geführt zuletzt
ermittelte die Polizei in über der
Hälfte der Fälle gegen Minderjährige und
Eltern damit wurden Polizei
Staatsanwaltschaften und Gerichte
blockiert blieb weniger Zeit für
wirkliche Täter der Mutter wurde der
Prozess gemacht sie wurde nur zu einer
Geldstrafe verurteilt weil das Gericht
keine höhere Strafe verhängen wollte in
Zukunft besteht die Möglichkeit in
bestimmten Fällen Verfahren auch wieder
einzustellen die Verbreitung von
Kinderpornographie Bilder zu bestrafen
klingt falsch ist aber richtig und
wichtig denn zuletzt musste die Polizei
in mehr als der Hälfte der Fälle gegen
die falschen gegen Minderjährige und
ihre Eltern Vorgehen im Zentrum muss
aber stehen gegen die echten Täter die
massenhaft den Missbrauch von Kindern im
Netz verbreiten vorzugehen und genau
dafür haben nun Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaft wieder die
Kapazität der Regen hat dem DFB
Pokalspiel Saarbrücken gegen Borussia
möncheng glladbach einen Strich durch
die Rechnung gemacht für die
Flugausfälle bei der Lufthansa ist der
Regen aber nicht verantwortlich wer
heute mit der Airline fliegen wollte der
musste sich Alternativen suchen denn das
Bodenpersonal der lufthanser streigt
noch bis morgen so kurz nach 7 der
Warnschuss wie werdi den 27stündigen
Ausstand nennt solle die Verhandler dazu
bringen in die in der nächsten Runde
doch etwas mehr auf den Tisch zu legen
also mehr Geld die Erholung der
lufthanser ein Milliarden in 2023 weckt
halt Begehrlichkeiten und als Bürger da
bekommt man den Eindruck nach Bauern und
Bahn irgendwas ist zur Zeit
immer Passagiere Einchecken Gepäck
transportieren Flugzeuge abfertigen wenn
sie die Arbeit niederlegen geht im
Flugbetrieb nicht mehr viel am Vormittag
versammeln sich Beschäftigte des
Bodenpersonals vor der
lufthanserzentrale in Frankfurt es hat
sich viel Frust angestaut bin leid
Kollegen zu sehen die jeden Monat von
ihrem Gehalt nicht leben können die ihr
Leben nicht finanzieren können und dann
kommt ein Angebot was ja noch nicht mal
die
Inflationsrate deckt die Gewerkschaft
fordert 12,5% mehr Gehalt mindestens
aber 500 € bei 12 Monaten Laufzeit und
lässt die Muskeln spielen 80 bis 90%
aller lufthanserflüge fallen heute aus
nur wer umbuchen konnte oder auf eine
andere Airline gebucht ist kann fliegen
die lufthanser fliegt nach den
schmerzhaften coronajahren wieder
Milliardengewinne ein dennoch sei der
Spielraum begrenzt wir haben aber
insgesamt großen Investitionsbedarf in
neue treibstoffärmere Flugzeuge in Sitze
in das Produkt in digitale
Reiseerlebnisse da gilt es viel
abzuwegen erst die Lockführer dann das
luftsicherheitspersonal und Beschäftigte
im ÖPNV die Streikbereitschaft der
Gewerkschaften ist gestiegen zum einen
weil sie unter dem Erwartungsdruck der
Beschäftigten stehen jetzt wieder höhere
reallöhner
rauszuhandeln und zum zweiten weil die
Gewerkschaften auch das Instrument des
Warnstreiks vor allen Dingen dazu nutzen
um eben neue Mitglieder zu gewinnen
Streiks mobilisieren und einigen die
Belegschaft wie heute zu sehen ist gibt
es kein verbessertes Angebot ist werdi
auch zu längeren Streiks
bereit das ist bei der nthstream
Pipeline Sabotage war das ist
unbestritten doch wer es war darüber
wird weiter gerätselt und ermittelt han
allerdings nicht mehr in Schweden na
ganz genau Schweden hat seine
Ermittlungen zu den Explosionen an den
nordstream Pipelines in der Ostsee
eingestellt die schwedische Justiz sei
nicht zuständig erklärte die
Staatsanwaltschaft in Stockholm zur
Begründung Beweisstücke seien nun an die
deutschen Behörden übergeben worden die
weiterhin ermitteln die Pipelines in der
Nähe der Insel Bornholm waren im
September
2022 durch Explosionen beschädigt
worden russland hat in der Nacht erneut
mehrere ukrainische Städte aus der Luft
angegriffen nach ukrainischen Angaben
wurden dabei mindestens fünf Menschen
getötet und mehr als 30 verletzt in Kiev
trafen Raketen unter anderem ein
18stöckiges Wohnhaus in Teilen der
Hauptstadt fiel infolge der Angriffe
stundenlang der Strom aus im
südukrainischen mikolajev sollen
dutzende Wohngebäude zerstört worden
sein bei der Bewertung der
Kreditwürdigkeit etwa durch die Schufa
sollen bestimmte Daten künftig nicht
mehr genutzt werden dürfen dazu zählen
unter anderem die Adresse der Name oder
die Herkunft das Bundeskabinett hat
heute eine Gesetzesänderung auf den Weg
gebracht und reagiert damit auf ein
Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshofs das
Ziel ist ein besserer Schutz vor
Diskriminierung bei den vorgezogenen
Präsidentschaftswahlen in Aserbaidschan
zeichnet sich ein Sieg des autoritären
Amtsinhabers aliev ab nach Auszählung
von von etwas mehr als der Hälfte der
Wahlbezirke kommt er nach Angaben der
Zentralen Wahlkommission auf
92,1% der Stimmen Beobachter kritisieren
die Wahl jedoch als weder frei noch fair
gewählt wurde auch in der Region
berkarabach die im vergangenen Herbst
erobert
wurde die EU-Kommission hat ein weiteres
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
Ungarn eingeleitet dem EU-Mitglied wird
vorgeworfen mit einem erst kürzlich
verabschiedeten Gesetz gegen
demokratische Grundsätze zu verstoßen
und damit europäisches Recht zu
verletzen Ungarn will dennoch an dem
sogenannten souveränitätsgesetz
festhalten dass die
Wahlkampffinanzierung aus dem Ausland
auch für Vereine und andere
Organisationen verbietet das Land hat
nun zwei Monate Zeit um auf die Vorwürfe
zu
reagieren ein Tag vor der Parlamentswahl
in Pakistan sind bei Anschlägen
mindestens 28 Menschen getötet worden
dutzende weitere wurden verletzt die
Explosionen ereigneten sich in der Nähe
von zwei wahlkampfbüros die terrormiliz
islamischer Staat hat die Anschläge für
sich reklamiert morgen sind rund 130
Millionen Wahlberechtigte zur
Stimmabgabe
aufgerufen alles auf grün umbauen
während der Betrieb läuft und dabei noch
konkurrenzfähig bleiben das ist eine
Herkules Aufgabe vor der nicht nur die
deutsche Wirtschaft steht keine Frage
aber die Klimaziele sollen ja
schließlich auch er werden ganz ohne
Hilfe geht das alles nicht und so hat
sich die EU nun auf ein Förderprogramm
für grüne Technologien geeinigt mit dem
sogenannten net Zero industry Act will
die EU die lokale Produktion sauberer
Technologien ausbauen die Erwartungen
sind hoch aber eines ist niedrig bis gar
nicht vorhanden und zwar hier frisches
Geld das haben die Amerikaner mit ihrem
Inflation reduction reduction Act den
Europäern also mal wieder voraus Isabel
schfers Solarmodul Produktion in Dresden
120 Mitarbeiter beschäftigt die Firma
solarwat in dieser Sparte und die tut
sich schwer womöglich müssen die
Mitarbeiter bald in anderen Bereichen
unterkommen muss die
solarmodulproduktion eingestellt werden
bei den rahungen die wir jetzt haben das
heißt auf einen Seite asiatische
Produkte die zumindestens mal im Preis
schwer nachvollziehbar sind wenn man
wenn man schaut ähm wie Herstellkosten
sind auf der anderen Seite Amerika
grenzenicht macht weil sie eben diese
Produkte nicht mehr ins Land lassen ähm
dann sind das Wettbewerbsbedingungen die
einfach einfach nicht mehr equal sind
nicht mehr fair sind das will die EU nun
ändern ausgewählte Schlüsseltechnologien
wie z.B Windenergie Batteriezellen und
photovoltaikanlagen werden künftig
gefördert europäische Anbieter sollen
bevorzugt werden auch wenn Ihr Angebot
etwas teurer ist Genehmigungsverfahren
werden beschleunigt bis 2030 soll die EU
so mindestens 40% ihres jährlichen
Bedarfs an sauberen Technologien
selbstdecken können es ist natürlich
auch eine Aussage in Richtung Industrie
dass wir eben nicht nur Klimawandel
machen wollen und dann sagen die
Technologie kaufen wir in China und in
Amerika sondern wir sagen ganz konkret
wir wollen das in Europa produziert wird
wir geben dafür auch einen Bonus wir
beschleunigen die
Genehmigungsverfahren und damit sind wir
relativ optimistisch dass wir auf so
eine Zielgröße von 40% kommen können die
USA fördern ihren Standort mit
Milliarden schweren Subventionen die EU
unternimmt mit ihrem neuen net Zero Act
auch den Versuch international mithalten
zu können aber der europäische Plan
sieht keine direkten Finanzmittel
vor es fehlt ein bisschen die
finanzielle Ausstattung da haben die
Mitgliedsstaaten leider zu wenig
reingegeben im Vergleich zu dem was die
Amerikaner mit ihrem Inflation
reductions Act anbieten allerdings ist
das amerikanische Konzept auch stark auf
Verschuldung basiert und man muss
schauen wie langfristig die Amerikaner
es sich leisten können so viel Geld zu
investieren ein Maßnahmenpaket zwei
Ziele die europäische Wirtschaft
wettbewerbsfähiger machen und
gleichzeitig den eigenen Klimazielen
näher
kommen das in Berlin mal etwas anders
läuft als geplant ist ja keine
Seltenheit die peinlichste Angelegenheit
in den letzten Jahren lässt sich in drei
Buchstaben ganz kurz zusammenfassen
B der Bau des Flughafens hat ne Jahre
länger gedauert und bis zu 5 Milliarden
mehr gekostet dicht gefolgt im Ranking
der Peinlichkeiten die Bundestagswahl
2021 da liefen diverse Dinge schief sass
an diesem Sonntag in einigen
Wahlbezirken neu gewählt werden muss an
der Stimmverteilung im Bundestag wird
das so gut wie nichts ändern dennoch sei
es keine Wahl für die Tonne denn auf die
Stimmung kommt es an heißt es Markus
groß Tür Wahlkampf mit Kevin küert die
erste Hürde die Eingangstür ist schnell
genommen so nehmen am liebsten der SPD
general wirbt um jede Stimme hallo
entschuldigen Sie die Störung K ist mein
Name ab seine SPD verliert Anhänger und
Zustimmung kein einfacher Wahlkampf in
diesen politisch aufgewühlten Zeiten es
Wlen ja bundesweit gesehen nur ganz
wenige Menschen es geht also nicht darum
dass der Deutsche Bundestag nach dieser
Wiederholungswahl ein anderer wird aber
es wird symbolträchtig auf diese Wahl
geguckt wie stark wird die AFD wie stark
werden die demokratiefeinde wie viele
gehen zur Wahl wieder mal Wahlkampf in
Berlin der dritte in 3 Jahren doch
dieser kommt eher lustlos daher wenige
Plakate bekannte Slogans die CDU wittert
ihre Chance mit einer
antiampelkampagne Wahlkampf der
besonderen Art so etwas was wir jetzt
hier machen hat was gespenstisches das
hat es ja noch nie gegeben die eine
Straßenseite kriegt eine W achrichtigung
die andere nicht wenn wir hier mit
Leuten reden sagen die Hälfte sie haben
noch keine Wahlbenachrichtigung bekommen
und dann muss ich die enttäuschen sagen
dann dürfen sie auch nicht wählen die
Wahlkarte ein Flickenteppich 550 000
Berliner können in
455 Wahllokalen erneut abstimmen nur ein
Fünftel der Wahlberechtigten so hat es
das Verfassungsgericht nach den massiven
wahlpannen
entschiedenon Grünen die
Familienministerin und
auf Werbetour auf der Straße muss sie
sich einiges
anhören verbessern Sie bitte Ihre
Kommunikation ansonsten weß ich nicht
was aus diesem Lande werden wir
streitende der Ampel miese umfrageerte
auch die Grünen unter Druck die aktuelle
Diskussion um die AFD soll eigene Wähler
mobilisieren diese Wahl ist eben wichtig
weil es ist die erste Wahl in diesem
entscheidenden wah 2024 und ich würde
mich sehr freuen wenn von Berlin wenn
auch nur für 45 Wahllokale klares
Zeichen ausgeht gegen Rechts Götz
frömeng AFD Kandidatin Panko zeigt sich
von den antifd Protesten der letzten
Wochen
unbeeindruckt ich denke mal dass wir
unser Ergebnis jetzt der allgemeinen
Stimmungslage geschuldet deutlich
verbessern werden das letzte Mal lagen
wir hier in Berlin nur bei knapp 9% das
wird diesmal deutlich mehr sein in
aktuellen Umfragen bröckelt allerdings
die Zustimmung zur AFD schon ein Trend
so kurios die Wahl in auch sein mag das
Ergebnis gilt als Signal für das
wichtige Wahljahr die ampelmehrheit so
viel steht fest ist nicht in
Gefahr das Viertelfinale im dfbpokal
zwischen Saarbrücken und Gladbach fiel
ja heute aus habe ich schon erwähnt zu
viel Regen Platz unbespielbar aber
Hanner woanders wurde gekickt ja ganz
genau in der Fußball buundesliga wurde
heute gespielt und zwar die
Nachholpartie zwischen Mainz 05 und
Union Berlin Endstand ein Z ein
Unentschieden das Spiel war Mitte Januar
wegen winterlicher Witterungsbedingungen
und eines damit verbundenen
Sicherheitsrisikos für die Zuschauer
abgesagt
worden die deutschen Biathletinnen und
Biathleten haben zum auftagt der
Weltmeisterschaften im tschechischen Nov
niesto die ersehnte Medaille verpasst in
der mixstaffel belegte das DSV Quartett
am Ende nur den fünften
Platz für Franziska preus konnte die
Enttäuschung kaum größer sein als erste
nach den beiden Männern strele und
navrad ins Rennen gegangen reichten ihr
vor 20.000 nassgeregneten Zuschauern im
Stehendanschlag auch alle drei Nachlader
nicht um die Strafrunde zu vermeiden der
anschließende Stolperer ein Sinnbild für
einen gebrauchten
Tag ja irgendwie ist mir Laktat so
reingeschossen und schon in Schand
Einlauf oder so in Schand rein war ich
schon extrem angespannt die neuen Mix
Meister kommen aus Frankreich vor
Norwegen und Schweden die deutsche
Schlussläuferin Vanessa Vogt kommt als
fünfte über die
Ziellinie zu den Lottozahlen an diesem
Mittwoch die lauten 1 8 15 19 26 21
Superzahl 0 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewehr vi noch der Blick aufs Wetter es
gibt
Unwetterwarnungen für Teile von
Nordrhein-Westfalen reheinlandpfalz und
Hessen vor ergiebigem Dauerregen morgen
regnet es in der Mitte anhaltend am
Nachmittag vom Emsland bis Sachsen teils
mit Schnee die Höchstwerte liegen
zwischen 3° in Thüringen und 14° am
oberrein am Freitag regnet es viel im
Norden mit Schnee der Samstag wird
unbeständig am Sonntag Regen im
Südwesten die Temperatur steigt auf 2
bis 17° am Samstag auch
darüber und das an Karneval t Fasching
fasteloven Fasenacht oder wie auch immer
das bei ihnen heißt ja Regenschirm nicht
vergessen ne ich werde einen dabei haben
und hier wartet jetzt Markus Lanz auf
sie und morgen übernimmt hier an dieser
Stelle Christian sieas machen sie es gut
wo auch immer sie sind
[Musik]
tschüss